in the last episode we went over the
main secrets in the DLC and as I'm sure
you noticed it's so easy to think you've
found everything but there's always more
secrets tucked away for example until
very recently I did not know Medea had a
gravattack when I first be familiar it
was with a silver knight leader of
cosplay and in the five hours it took to
deplete midis gigantic health pool
I remember continuously thinking man
Ledo could have looked so much better
because a few days before release
hundreds of assets were data mined from
the Ring City patch and amongst these
were the UI icons for a certain armor
set look closely at it so it's a well
worn silver Knight set and it has a few
extra modifications to set it apart from
the other standard sets of the Legion
just look at those horns it would have
been so perfect for Ledo
because he's described as an eccentric
silver Knight a man wearing well-worn
armor from his distant travels around
the outskirts of the world
another thing that didn't make it in are
a few more lines of dialogue from the
locust preacher this creature gives
exposition on many characters of Dark
Souls 3 and if my source is correct he
was supposed to also say of all the
fingers he alone was embraced by the
abyss for he was human and never a grub
fear not the dark my friend and let the
feast again so he's describing a finger
of rosario but which one for a little
bit of background fingers of Rosaria our
red phantoms who invade kill and pillage
for their own benefit and together
tongues for their mistress in return
they can be reborn though those who are
reborn one too many times run the risk
of turning into grubs something that
does happen to yellow finger hazel in
fact of all the fingers he alone was
embraced by the
for he was human and never agro so place
your bets who do you think this is
describing there are only really three
options for there are only three male
fingers of Brazoria [ __ ] the wanderer
ring finger Leonardo and middle finger
Kirk personally I think it's Leonardo in
this dialogue he was the one who
eventually stole rosaria's soul in some
misguided effort to keep it safe I
believe he's the finger in question
because the dialogue says he was human
and never a grub and Leonardo's
described multiple times as rejecting
rebirth and the restoration of his
scarred flesh therefore unlike the other
fingers he would never risk turning into
a grump and losing his unity of course
for whatever reason this dialogue was
removed which makes it unwise to draw
conclusions but it is interesting
nonetheless
for what does it mean to be embraced by
the abyss that's something we'll go into
an hour locust video I promised so keep
an eye for them speaking of locusts have
you ever tried to listen to the locusts
below the swamp they say a variation of
dying
and
Kikki while I was straining my ears
listening for this fairly pointless
dialogue so I could fill out my 20
questions I noticed that the abdomen of
the locusts is remarkably similar to
that of the Angels look at the
iridescent wings and the stinger in
particular are these reused assets or is
there some parallel to be drawn between
the two creatures or am I trying really
hard to make this a valid point to
include in the video who knows just
above the locusts is lap in what can
potentially be the last place you meet
him - someone tell me Who am I why am I
here keep revisiting him here and after
reloading the game three times we get
solid proof that lap was not lying about
forgetting his name and he was not lying
about going hollow if you make him
hostile here you can unlock a more
satisfying ending to lap story the lap
arc of patches quest line is really well
executed and you have to love the clues
they give you from the signature squat
the slightly tuned voice and especially
the part where he risks his life to find
you treasure if you failed to pick it up
but did you know that it was always
possible to guess who that was simply
from his name a lap is a word in middle
high german that is used to describe a
simple-minded person or it's ironically
used to call a smart person a fool and
obviously this suit slacks to an insane
degree because he's both lost his mind
and it's ironic that of all the
intelligent people to lose their minds
it would be our best friend patches
furthermore in middle high german the
name lap also refers to a mender of
clothes or shoes and was used to
describe a cloth a rag or a patch black
also means patch in swedish anyway after
you've talked to lap about the ring city
you can track this information back to
its source
why where did you hear
name love oh it doesn't matter I'll tell
you what I know the Rings city is said
to be at World's End past this heap of
rubbish as far as one can go but you
better think twice the forsaken ring
city was walled off by the gods to
contain the pygmies and the Dark Soul is
better left well alone
number eight have you noticed what I'm
serving towards these parts of the Drake
heap are on an endless trip downwards
and you have to wonder are they meant to
provide the illusion from a distance
that the Drake heap is collapsing
downwards and inwards or was this just
an asset that they forgot to lock in
place and some drag heap assets should
feature more prominently in my opinion
for example if you look left at the very
edge of the drop down to the demon
Prince you can see the entire undead
settlement cobbled together here and
further down in the demon Prince arena
there's the rubble of the first filing
shrine you can even find the well and
the stones dead circle at the center and
of course don't forget this part of the
grand archives this rooftop you can jump
to in early lothric this room where you
first encounter lava ignites the
courtyard in lothric with two enormous
snakes when whoa I had this tweeted at
me right at best signal on Twitter who
discovered these giant ash coated snakes
that bleed he posits that they might be
primordial servants but if they are they
certainly lack the familiar features the
signature nose the teeth the moustache
thing no whatever these are I'm not sure
they're from any age we know of note
however that they are impaled with the
weapons of the lothric Knights as if a
battle took place here number 11 with
every major drop in the drag heap
there's the ghost of Gale to guide you
but did you notice also he's ripped off
a part of his red cloak and weighted
down with a stone these additional
markers show you where to go a bit he
regrets it now that cloak probably could
have done with the extra range in the
boss fight the most significant piece of
red cloth is located in the shared grave
of the Ring City signifying the drops
downwards that's necessary to progress
you upwards speaking of does patches
really screw you over with his final
kick
or is this him trying to help you and
while we're on the topic of red cloth
yeah I know it's not really in the ring
City but it was added with the ring city
patch on stains plume thanks to a small
change.org petition was added and it
might have been a simpler task because
there was an edition of the dragon
slayer armor which also had a similar
plume and similar cloth physics another
thing added with the patch was these
humanity sprite icons which signifies
which bonfire location is the most
active so whether it's for PvP or for
co-op use these to your advantage number
fourteen one area you can't access
despite it being plastered everywhere as
promotional material is this lonely
tower just past the first judicata giant
and if you get the judicata giant to
throw you over there you discover that
there's nothing inside interestingly
enough though there are these statues
that you found around
IRRI fill though who thereof has always
been a bit of a mystery and given that
they're meant to be out of eyeshot I
doubt this is much more than a reused
asset and never meant to be seen up
close and my god
were some things not meant to be seen up
close
in the world brought to ruin by the
breaking of the shell our to crumbled
kingdoms off in the distance
one is lothric 100% is even a 3d model
you can get close to and look at
properly but further in a blurry 2d
asset at the edge of the end of the
world is this structure it has elements
of Anor Londo it has elements of that
old drangleic footage we saw but
whichever it is I think that they're
trying to convey that this place at the
end of the world
contains the ruins of the most
significant kingdoms and lothric being
featured so prominently here leads me to
believe that our unconditionally the
most significant of all as an aside this
place at the end is what you saw in the
opening cutscene with a pilgrim come to
die outside the ruins of lothric
[Music]
and no let's go without rim and of
course the Lords of cinder weren't the
only ones to abandon their thrones so
too would the pygmy Lords one of whom
crawls towards Fillion or Massoud is
dedicated look at his skull disconnected
entirely from his spine I decided to
devote about 67 gigabytes of file space
to record this guy's journey all for
this incredible tale you know I'm sure a
bunch of you guys did this too
it's the end of the game you have to
drag it out somehow number 17 the big
question is what exactly does Fillion or
zeg represent and how exactly does it
add askew the pygmy Lords and the Dark
Soul and this end of the world scene and
it's fairly well established that
wherever this is it's in the future for
example gales weaponry is incredibly
warned the pygmy Lords have heard rumors
of a Red Hood coming to devour them and
of course the entire world has fallen to
ash and I'm still working on my theories
but right now I believe maybe the time
passed
naturally for everyone else except us
with their world slowly grinding down to
ash but for us it seems like we were
fast forwarded to more or less the exact
moment Fillion all would eventually die
for a pygmy is crawling to her somehow
still expecting her to be alive I'm
getting our stomach sorry I'm just
really keen to make the main story video
for this place but what I wanted to
bring up Thor at this point was that
there's this obscure animated film by
tokuma shoten called angels egg and
without a doubt Miyazaki was inspired by
this film when creating villian ORS
design and I hoped to watch it and
discover the meaning of the egg through
this film we're actually going to have a
movie night where we stream and watch
the movie together over on my discord so
check out the description for that
another theory I've seen about the egg
has been thrown around ever since
Fillion gnaws design was shown and it
talks about the resemblance between
Fillion or zeg and the vagrants of Dark
Souls 1 and have to agree then is a
resemblance
look at them they're cracked in much the
same way with a coarse dark interior and
remember these creatures were only
present in Dark Souls 1 which was during
the close of the age of the gods so even
from a timeline point of view it makes
sense that Fillion or who was likely
placed here in the age of the gods may
have possessed one of the last vagrants
these mysterious creatures used to
appear in other people's worlds if you
dropped items or if you lost a large
amount of humanity in your own world and
very very interestingly the cracked
fragrance simply drop humanity and twin
humanity suggesting that the humanity
fragments of the Dark Soul might have
made up that dark interior and for an
egg with a black inside that obscures
the dark soul of humanity from those who
would claim it this feels very
significant speaking of time passing
after you've used the envoi banner to
arrive in the ringed City time passes in
re and L and the fire that you lit to
eventually engulf re and L takes root in
the chapel but that's not the only
visual change in the outside world
because as noticed by zones n on reddit
there are now more trees in Ferren keep
did they really need more trees here I
didn't realize I mean it looks a bit
nicer but why this baffles me if they
decided to devote development time to
this then what else in the outside world
has changed well one thing has the
epilogue of Dark Souls 3 the song played
in the credits after you beat the saw
Cinda has changed it's become a little
bit more powerful and with a few more
instrumentals I'm going to just let this
play for a little while so we can let
the end of souls sink in all of it I'll
see you next time
in our story explanation of the Ring
City also thank you to the ton of new
patrons we got in the last video this
video would have gone out earlier for
you guys but as you can probably tell I
got really really sick and I didn't even
think I could narrate hopefully my voice
doesn't sound terrible it will be does
I'm going to listen back to it now I'll
see in the next one thanks for watching
goodbye
[Music]